I'm working a broken toe cast on to end up
with a nice tubular edge for my ribbing.
My needles are arranged for one by one
ribbing, and I'll start
with a zigzag cast on.
Both carriages are set for plain knitting.
I'll hang the ribber cast on comb,
making sure the comb is hanging
in the loops of the ribber needles.
Next, I'll disengage the ribber carriage
the carriage from the main carriage,
pass it, and drop all the ribber loops.
The cast on comb will be
hanging in those loops.
I'll pass the carriage back and rejoin
the ribber and the main bed carriages.
There are no changes to the carriages yet.
I'll knit another zigzag row.
Notice that the main bed now has stitches
and the ribber now has new loops.
At this point, I'll hang
weights in my cast on comb.
Next, I'll knit
the tubular rows with slip.
I'll set the main bed to slip in one
direction and the ribber to slip
in the opposite direction.
In other words, I'm going to knit only
the ribber stitches first,
then knit only the main bed stitches,
then knit only the ribber stitches.
I'll finish by canceling slip on both
carriages and set for plain knitting,
and then knit one row in ribbing.
Following my pattern,
I'll continue knitting in ribbing.
When the ribbing rows are complete,
I'll transfer the ribber
stitches to the main bed.
When all of the stitches are up
on the main bed, I can drop the ribber,
follow my pattern and continue knitting.
Once the knitting is off the machine,
there's a strand of yarn passing
through the loops of that cast-on edge.
Opposite the cut end of yarn that was used
for cast-on,
pull the strand and gather the edge.
Hit this edge with a shot
of steam and set the stitches.
This will eliminate any flare
and create a beautiful cast-on edge.